began in Sudan where heavy fighting is
threatening a fragile ceasefire to allow
in much needed humanitarian Aid a
fighter jet was shot down in onderman
northwest of Khartoum and artillery fire
has been reported near a military base
the Sudanese Army and the Rival
paramilitary group the rapid support
forces have been locked in a power
struggle for more than a month Saudi
Arabia and the U.S brokered the
ceasefire on Monday Iber Morgan has more
from the city of onderman
residents in the cities of umdarman and
hortum reported that they were able to
hear gunfire overnight being exchanged
between the rapid support forces and the
Sudanese Army now in the early hours of
Thursday we were able to hear
reconnaissance planes flying overhead in
the city of Underman and when we spoke
to people in Khartoum City they say that
they also are able to hear the plane
this comes after a day of heavy fighting
between the rsf and the Sudanese Army
the rsf claims that it shot down a
fighter jet belonging to the Army but
the Army says that the plane crashed due
to a technical error on the parts of the
plane and that it was not due to a
surface-to-air missile being fired by
the rapid support forces fighting on
Wednesday also ensued in the city of
hartum in the western part around the
currency printing press now the Army
says that the rsf despite the ceasefire
took over the building for a few hours
and that they had to attack to defend
the building now all this is a violation
of the ceasefire fighter jets should not
be flying overhead and and the use of
heavy artillery especially in
residential areas should not be
happening so this ceasefire in the first
two days did not hold people here in
Horton State say that they hope that the
third day Thursday would actually prove
to be better than the first and the
second day of the ceasefire because of
the humanitarian situation on the ground
especially when it comes to the medical
situation for those who are in need of
medical assistance we visited a hospital
in umdurman on Wednesday and this is
what we saw
normally Anwar bakri brings her mother
to a renal dialysis center twice a week
but since the start of fighting getting
access to a hospital with the needed
facilities has been difficult
it's the start of the war the health
we went to another hospital and started
there but they were only able to do the
dialysis for two hours
we tried several others but cartoon
Mills generally has no power running
water this is my mother's first Dialysis
in two weeks
most of the patients in the dialysis
were here in elno hospital in umdur Man
City have traveled to get here the
fightings led to most of the 29
hospitals in Khartoum unable to function
Healthcare facilities have been under
pressure since the start of the conflict
some have had to turn away patients
because they don't have the space or
medicine to treat them others have
closed their doors out of fear of being
caught up in the fighting or because of
damages to their buildings
this hospital is one of the few
remaining providing renal treatments to
patients but the staff say they may not
be able to do so for long
patients who come in need dialysis three
times a week can only get one session
and even the dialysis is changing here
due to a shortage in its needs we don't
have enough dialyzers or artificial
kidneys today is the last day for us to
treat kidney patients we don't even have
tubes and gloves there's nothing left
medical staff are in short supply
volunteers help run the hospital's
operations
I'm here because of my sense of
responsibility and nationalism this is
my country and this is the least I can
offer the people who come here are our
friends Brothers neighbors and even if
we don't know them we're all the same
blood so we all need to stand together
a ceasefire signed between the warring
parties is meant to open humanitarian
corridors for those in need of medical
assistance but the fighting continues
threatening to make a dire situation
even worse
Hiba Morgan Al Jazeera onderman
the Tariq is a social activist a member
of the garifna movement she's in an area
of the capital where fighting is taking
place
right now I'm in eastern 15 minutes away
from the military headquarters which is
also a main point of the fights in the
world started and we've been hearing and
actually we saw the uh the fighting jet
um yesterday around 1pm it was flying we
were actually shocked because uh people
had so much High Hopes on this ceasefire
and then after that we were hearing
artillery and also random shooting
inside the neighborhood my neighborhood
one of the um very much occupied or like
artistic controlled neighborhoods in
cartoon so we're seeing so many of them
just randomly shooting sometimes at
people sometimes just to terrorize the
neighborhood in and it's very random
also this morning we've been hearing um
um the sounds of a very heavy fighting
coming from his cartoon on the other
side closer to the military headquarters
soldiers on the ground are terrorizing
people robbing people looting houses so
it's not safe to move a few people able
to move because the situation is
different from a neighborhood to another
most of the people unable to get money
because most of the people are very poor
and it's actually
um affecting people as very much because
if even if you have in some areas if you
have access to money you don't have
access to services and vice versa